[Music]
on this tuesday night progress in bc's
long road to recovery
a crucial rail line reopens while some
merit residents return to new rules what
you are coming home to
is a city that's changed throne speech
the trudeau government's game plan and
what was missing
families torn apart i worked with
canadian forces and they are paying for
it the heartbreaking toll of canada's
resettlement program for afghan refugees
and boulevards of blockchain dreams
there's lots of potential el salvador's
blueprint for a bitcoin city and a
volcano's vital role
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin once again in british
columbia where there are some
significant signs of progress after last
week's catastrophic flooding people who
were forced from their homes are allowed
back in and a key rail line has reopened
that will help ease supply chain issues
but the economic damage has been done
the bank of montreal predicts the cost
of bc's flood disaster will exceed 7.5
billion dollars that's what calgary's
flood cost in 2013 but bmo's economists
say this flood is bigger and its impact
is wider the repairs to roadways and
rail lines damaged by the rain and
landslides will be no small feat in some
places it will require the complete
reconstruction of the ground beneath
these vital arteries our mike armstrong
looks at the mountainous task ahead and
the supply chain backlog building up
this is basically the end of the road
and an important one highway 1 the trans
canada is normally the main route
between bc's lower mainland and the rest
of the country
it's also clark bibi's way home to
alberta it's a disaster
until they get a highway open up or they
get double angle and it's going to be
like
crazy
right now one side of this stretch of
the highway is open but only to
essential traffic and emergency vehicles
and further down it's closed completely
people in the area are used to a
constant hum of traffic normally eighty
thousand vehicles pass by here every day
including more than twelve thousand
trucks
they're ways around but they're long
so what's happening dave earl is the
president of the bc truckers association
whereas before you could do a run from
here to calgary
just about within a 12 or 13 hour run
that's just not possible now it's taking
well over a day
further north water isn't the problem
it's washouts and landslides on multiple
highways in dozens of locations the
provincial transport minister isn't
mincing his words the coca-cola highway
he says could be closed for many months
the entire trucking industry is
scrambling to reconfigure essentially
how it does everything one change
already the number of hours truckers can
spend behind the wheel has been extended
if they're carrying essential goods
now there is progress on the rail side
both cp and cnn have been down for more
than a week that's created bottlenecks
and backlogs and cut off the lower
mainland well cp said it reopened
tuesday while cns as it plans to reopen
wednesday
now consider what that means this is a
spot called tank hill just west of the
town of spence's bridge just a few days
ago the rail line was hanging with
nothing underneath it's now set to
reopen
both rail companies were already moving
equipment during last week's storm and
crews were deployed as soon as the rain
stopped cp says in making repairs it's
moved the equivalent of 30 000 one-ton
dump trucks of earth rock and other
materials it's just extraordinary i mean
the repair work that's been done the
remediation work it is just breathtaking
i mean to tell you how fast stuff is
happening cnn applied for a blasting
permit it took them 30 minutes to get it
through
now one issue that makes road repairs
more complicated is that it isn't just a
matter of fixing what's broken
everything has to be checked by
engineers as well and not just from the
air some problems you only see from the
ground
up close
mike armstrong global news abbotsford bc
there is also some movement tonight in
one of bc's hardest hit communities some
residents of merit are finally being
allowed back home the city with a
population of seven thousand was
completely evacuated more than a week
ago global's darien matassa fung is
tracking the return for us tonight
darian
robin there weren't the long lines that
might have been expected to get back
into merit today as residents were
trickling back into their homes as they
returned to their city we're excited to
be home
yeah
tasha illingworth felt relief to be
returning home even with the uncertainty
of exactly what she'd be going back to
their community isn't the same anymore
and that lots of people have lost their
homes and that there's lots of
rebuilding that needs to be done and
just we don't know what the school will
look like for all the kiddos
she's one of 7 000 people who were
forced to flee after the massive
flooding that caused the local
wastewater system to completely fail
nearly two thousand were allowed to
return tuesday phase one of merit's
three-part return plan for areas where
hydro gas and internet are still
functioning most of the city's services
are still down the hospital is not
operational 911 calls are being rerouted
to kamloops almost 100 kilometers north
the town's water system is online but
there is a boil water advisory in effect
the water isn't safe to drink residents
are being asked to use as little water
as possible to protect the system for
the fire department
and they're being told to use the sewage
system as little as possible right now
sewage cannot be processed city
officials warn this isn't the same city
they left what you are coming home to
is a city that's changed
you will be on a boil water advisory
because the health officials tell us the
water is not safe to drink
mayor city officials do say they expect
to bring more residents home on thursday
but first need to make sure they have
drinkable water first robin daryn
matassa fung in merit bc
the city of abbotsford is still cleaning
up from the last weather event and also
preparing for the next one another
atmospheric river is expected to hit the
region by thursday crews are frantically
repairing dikes the city is working with
environment canada to prepare for what
may come
we are using projections to anticipate
water levels and how they will intersect
with the status of our dikes
the main dike repair is now about 80
percent complete the city hopes to add
another five feet of height by thursday
before the heavy rain sets in
it's not an atmospheric river but a
powerful atlantic storm that's drenching
canada's east coast
environment canada issued rainfall
warnings across most of nova scotia
today and for the eastern tip of prince
edward island up to 120 millimeters of
rain are forecast to fall on parts of
mainland nova scotia and cape breton it
brought flooding to low-lying areas
around antigonish submerging some homes
the system moved in overnight with high
winds that knocked out electricity to
more than twelve thousand homes and
businesses several schools and halifax
were closed for the day due to the power
outages
the storm is a real soaker in
newfoundland and labrador where it could
drop as much as 400 millimeters of rain
in some places this satellite map shows
what a beast the system is wind warnings
are also in effect with powerful gusts
reaching up to 120 kilometers an hour
along southwestern portions of the rock
now to ottawa where the 44th session of
parliament was officially opened today
with the speech from the throne the
speech was delivered by governor general
mary simon there were few surprises as
promised during the election the
liberals say their top priority is
putting an end to the pandemic other
priorities include economic recovery
reconciliation and climate change for
more on the speech and the reaction
let's bring in our chief political
correspondent david aiken and david what
stood out for you
well robin it was a speech that made
history and repeated history
a first for canada a speech from the
throne read by an indigenous governor
general in french english and inuktitut
but it repeated themes from past trudeau
government speeches a familiar call for
bold action this is the moment for
parliamentarians to work together to get
big things done
and shape a better future for our kids
repeated promises to tackle housing
affordability child care and a warming
planet this is the moment for bolder
climate action a renewed vow first made
in 2015 to put the relationship with
indigenous peoples at the heart of
everything it does reconciliation
requires
a whole of government approach
breaking down barriers and ring
rethinking how to accelerate our work
but with few details on how it will do
all that the opposition quickly found
fault with the government's agenda today
we heard more of the same from the
trudeau government
what we didn't hear was a plan for the
economy a plan to tackle the cost of
living crisis they can't take our
support for granted and this isn't a
throne speech that looks like they want
to work together this is a government
that is trying to give off a sense of
movement a sense of action it promised
accelerated work on reconciliation
accelerated work on climate change it
even promised a housing accelerator fund
but the problem is the trudeau
government has often been criticized for
moving too slowly and so that is going
to be the challenge starting tomorrow
can the government transform itself to
match the pace promised in the speech
from the throne robin david aiken in
ottawa
for more analysis let's bring in our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stevenson
mercedes as david mentioned today's
speech was about accelerating the same
themes there wasn't much that was new
what's the strategy here
well robin if that speech gave you a
sense of deja vu you're certainly not
alone we've heard these ideas before and
they're the liberal election campaign
platform today was all about
transitioning away from introducing new
big bold ideas to actually implementing
them there are significant programs that
are listed here but they will require
billions of dollars to execute and lots
of details programs that many canadians
voted for but the devil is always in the
details on how to get things done and
that's something the government has
struggled with in the past and is still
notably absent but no question the point
of this speech is to really get down to
the
tactics of implementing their programs
so what was missing
what was missing to me was details on
how to address inflation beyond the
plans they already had in place that had
to do with the cost of housing and child
care i was also surprised there wasn't
anything on military sexual misconduct
and culture change in the military given
how much the government has said that
this is a priority for them they had
didn't recognize either in this speech
the phenomenal work of the canadian
armed forces both through the pandemic
and out in british columbia there wasn't
anything about the increasing issues
with the united states and the
protectionist policies of the biden
presidency that could seriously damage
the economy and finally not a lot of
details on what they will do for
albertan workers as they move forward on
capping the oil and gas industry can the
opposition work with the liberals on the
priorities in this speech
sure they can robin there's there's no
poison pills in here that would make
them take down the government and the
opposition liberals can both read the
room enough to know that absolutely
nobody wants another election right now
that said you could hear the parties
bickering already today on parliament
hill and while there's still lots of
room for negotiations canadians put the
parties on notice in the election they
expect them to work collaboratively
together and to avoid that kind of
nitpicking the liberals believe they
have a mandate to govern and they
certainly do but voters have also
signaled that they expect the prime
minister to compromise with opposition
parties and the liberal choice to wait
so long to introduce a throne speech
after a september election they called
is rubbing the opposition the wrong way
already robin compromise is key mercedes
stevenson in ottawa thank you
now to the efforts to get young children
vaccinated depending on where you live
vaccinations are already underway
tonight the mayor of toronto shared this
photo on twitter he says it's the first
group of children under 12 to be
vaccinated against coven 19 in canada
several provinces including ontario and
quebec launched their online booking
systems for children this morning
widespread rollouts are expected to
begin this week in british columbia
vaccinations will get underway next week
this is like a major step forward now in
continuing on the journey of getting our
communities back to
as close to normal as as we'll be
following the pandemic
in new brunswick and pei officials say
they hope to begin rolling out shots to
young children by the end of the week
the ramifications of canada's
resettlement program for afghan refugees
coming up why families are being split
apart
the canadian government has promised to
accept 40 000 afghan refugees but so far
fewer than 4 000 have arrived canada's
rescue plans were upended last summer
when the taliban took control leaving
hundreds who helped canada's military
mission trapped and in the chaos of the
evacuation efforts some families were
split in half jeff semple reports
fatima and her three-year-old son just
arrived in canada after escaping
taliban-controlled afghanistan but their
newfound freedom came at a price
leaving afghanistan was the hardest
decision she says we're protecting her
family's identity because fatima's
brother abdul was an interpreter with
the canadian military
as the taliban advanced in august abdul
received approval to move his family
from kandahar to canada but they arrived
at the airport to this
the family waited outside the gates for
two days when they finally reached the
entrance the canadian military told
abdul there wasn't enough room on the
plane for everyone they said no we
cannot take your whole family we can
take only your
siblings so they faced a heart-wrenching
choice fatima and her son were allowed
to board but her husband and the
couple's five-year-old daughter were
forced to stay behind in afghanistan
leaving was very hard she says my
daughter was crying after me and my son
was crying after his father
fatima told herself it was the right
decision that her son was safe and
hopefully her husband and daughter would
be on the next flight but the following
day isis isis-k terrorists attacked the
airport
killing dozens grounding flights and
forcing fatima's husband and daughter
into hiding
i can't eat or sleep she says i feel
empty inside i miss my daughter and my
husband
hello
we met fatima's husband in kabul where
he and his daughter have been moving
between safe houses for three months
they applied to go to canada in august
but haven't received a response
our five-year-old is crying every day
for her mother he says the situation
here is not stable or safe for us this
was you know a delicate situation that
should have been handled appropriately
and it wasn't this canadian ex-special
forces officer was at the airport in
august as the taliban took control his
private security firm has been working
to rescue afghans with canadian visas
but those evacuations have now stalled
canada's approval process is slow and
there are few safe routes out of the
country all these families that are just
waiting now it's hard waiting and
praying the taliban doesn't find their
loved ones left behind it's my family
i worked with canadian forces and they
are paying for it jeff sample global
news kabul afghanistan
still ahead the dramatic rescue of a
woman hanging by a thread from a high
rise
some absolutely terrifying moments for
an 80-year-old woman in southern china
local media is reporting that she fell
from her 19th floor balcony while
hanging laundry her legs caught on a
clothing rack on the floor below leaving
her dangling upside down police and
firefighters came to the rescue using a
rope to lower her to safety
in western bulgaria at least 45 people
including 12 children have been killed
in an early morning bus crash the
deadliest in the country's history the
bus was carrying mostly macedonian
tourists details of what happened are
unclear some people managed to escape
out of windows and are now recovering in
hospital
breaking news from a wisconsin
courthouse a sixth person a child has
now died after a man allegedly drove an
suv through a christmas parade near
milwaukee and a warning some of the
images may be disturbing 36-year-old
daryl brooks made his first court
appearance today he's charged with five
counts of intentional homicide but a six
count is expected more charges are being
considered with over 60 people injured
on sunday a doorbell camera captured
brooks asking for help from a resident
near the parade route it also shows
police arriving and arresting him
el salvador banks on building a city
fueled by bitcoin up next why a volcano
will play a critical role
the crustaceans on christmas island are
clogging roads and causing some traffic
jams millions of red crabs are making
their way to the ocean the mass
migration happens annually as part of
the crabs mating season nowhere else in
the world does this phenomenon occur on
such a grand scale each female can
produce up to a hundred thousand eggs
the christmas island red crab is unique
to australia and is protected by law
two months after el salvador became the
first country to adopt bitcoin as legal
tender the international monetary fund
is recommending the country reverse
course citing high risk to consumer
protection and financial stability but
the central american nation is doubling
down it's planning to build an entire
city backed by bitcoin bonds and as
redmond shannon explains it involves a
volcano too
another week another silicon valley
style bitcoin event from el salvador's
young president naive bouquet
so there you go go back don't show them
guys
it may not have been as smooth as an
iphone unveiling but its ambition is
huge an income tax-free bitcoin city
focused on mining the cryptocurrency
that's been legal tender in el salvador
since september and it's going to
include everything residential areas
commercial areas services ukele says the
city designed in the shape of a coin
will cost 300 000 bitcoins to build
right now that's about 20 billion
dollars he wants to raise the cash by
issuing bitcoin bonds and says the power
intensive crypto mining will be powered
by renewable energy from an unexpected
source this is a fully fully ecological
city that's worked that works and it's
energized
by a volcano el salvador currently gets
a quarter of its power from similar
geothermal tech my impression is that he
lives in a parallel world you know
a world of illusions environmentalist
ricardo navarro says buchelli's plan
optimistically assumes the volcano could
power the energy-hungry plan
what matters is the amount of
electricity is going to demand it
here in el salvador we don't have enough
electricity produced with our own means
we have to buy oil for that the devil's
in the details i think there's a lot
that's left to be uh explained about how
bitcoin city is going to work crypto
advocate alex tapscott thinks that if
nothing else bouquet's bitcoin exploits
have grabbed headlines for a poor nation
looking for investment there are risks
but i also think there's lots of
potential and i think that the
alternative is hardly desirable for the
country bouquet and the volcano two
sources of unpredictable power on which
el salvador is betting its future
redmond shannon global news
it's a whole new world and that is
global national for this tuesday i'm
robin gill tonight your canada is this
group of elk resting in the snow near
hinton alberta we would love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you